und was für ein Einsatz für Feuerwehr
und Polizei in Sachsen ganz genau in
Zwickau eine Einsatz in einem Bordell
bei dem eine Baggerschaufel diese
Baggerschaufel die entscheidende Rolle
gespielt hat sie wird zu rettenden
Schaufel der Baggerfahrer zum Helden
hier brennt ein Bordell flammenbrechen
durch das Dach qualmender Rauch ganz
komisch zitter jetzt noch
diese eigenartig trotzdem alles richtig
ich habe ja nicht viel gesehen aber ich
hoffe ich habe alles richtig gemacht ja
was war geschehen im Bordell brach aus
noch ungeklärter Ursache ein Feuer aus
betroffen bei der rückseitige Anbau in
dem nach Bildinformationen auch die dort
arbeitenden Frauen untergebracht sind
also ich habe es gar nicht mitbekommen
ich bin bei uns aus dem Bürogebäude
gekommen und da hatte Kunde von uns hat
gesagt ich soll mal schnell den Notruf
rufen ihr brennt
Baggerführer Volker mai ist an diesem
Tag zum Helden geworden er und sein
Bagger haben Leben gerettet
zwei Frauen aus Tschechien sind bei
Ausbruch des Feuers noch im Gebäude
während die jüngere sich unverletzt aus
dem Brandhaus retten kann sitzt die
andere Frau im Obergeschoss fest in
panische Angst rettet sie sich mit einem
Sprung vom Giebelfenster des brennenden
Hauses auf das etwa drei Meter tiefer
gelegene Vordach bleibt dort zunächst
verletzt liegen
wieder brauchen eine Leiter hier oben
ist noch jemand im Gebäude und dann
wollte eine Leiter haben und da bin ich
schnell losgefahren und habe unseren
Radlader geholt und habe sie dann mit
den Sunnys vom garagentochrunner gehoben
und dass er transportfähig war die Frau
kommt mit schweren Verletzungen in eine
Klinik ist aber außer Lebensgefahr war
es Brandstiftung
also ist es jetzt zurzeitig sich zu
äußern die brandursachermittlung der
Kriminalpolizei ist vor Ort und die
haben die Ermittlungen aufgenommen da
wird man später dann sicherlich etwas
erfahren
am Haus entstand großer Sachschaden nach
den Löscharbeiten klafft im Dach ein
Loch die Polizei ermittelt derzeit zur
Brandursache doch Volker mai ist
glücklich dass er mit seinem Bagger
Leben retten konnte
[Musik]